[Music]
it's curious you're playing the Russian
Captain America so I guess the big
question I want to know is how old are
you in the film I mean they're not gonna
CGI my face because there's a lot of I
guess I'm trying to dig down on the
serum stuff if there's a you know what
I'm saying
I do that gets discussed in the film I
think that yeah he's uh you know he's oh
he's a real time guy so his 2016 like
you know real time it's kept the events
take place after or Civil War and he's
real time it's waged up for me but it's
you know that all gets resolved in the
thing but it yeah he's about you know
I'm on the level with him is that each
one seems to take the comic book genre
and push it a new direction yeah how
does Black Widow do that so a good
question I mean first of all it does
feel I don't mean to say you know like
the they all kind of have their own
Brent like they do the Marvel thing
which they do very well which like
there's Loni always a lot of humor
always a lot Hart right
but like you look at something like thor
ragnarok and then you look you know like
this sort of kind of silly world of Tyco
and all this stuff that they do and then
this is like Kate Shortland is very much
at the helm of this and if you watch her
films like a somersault or lore like
there's a real vulnerability to her
filmmaking and a real indie sort of
sensitivity to the things that she's
drawn to and she's really bringing that
to this film so it feels like you know
it's grounded in a sense of like this
espionage and also really in terms of
this
with Natasha on what she's struggling
with and what she's going through so it
has all these like big more violence and
then but at its essence it feels like a
character piece you know very much like
a almost delicate character piece about
this woman who's struggling with
something thank you so much for your on
thanks I look forward to in stranger
things season four